so because so a few of you were
interested in seeing any Star Wars
videos on my channel instead we're going
to jump back into Darkseid war and cover
some of the one shots following the
conclusion of act one starting with
Batman however if you are interested in
seeing some Star Wars content you can
head over to rob explains and view it
there
so the Batman one shot from Darkseid war
was written by Peter Tomasi and provides
us with a view of Gotham City following
Batman's acquisition of the mobius chair
and his ability to know all things that
villains have done and are doing now
what makes this coming particularly
interesting to me is that it takes a
dichotomy between Batman and the law and
throws it into sharp relief what I mean
here is that when Bruce Wayne meets Jim
Gordon after he's activated the
bat-signal he makes the case that Gordon
doesn't need to do this anymore
due to the fact that Bruce knows
everything that's happening in Gotham at
the moment to sidetrack for a second for
those of you who have been reading Jim
Gordon Batman
much like Darkseid wore proper the
continuity of this story in relation to
Batman's solo series is unknown
and at this point we can only really
guess as to when it takes place however
the fact remains that the reason for Jim
Gordon's fear of Bruce Wayne is due to
the fact that where he previously went
with the evidence at hand examined it
and came to a clear and rational
conclusion which could stand in the
court of law with the möbius chair while
it does grant him absolute knowledge on
what every criminal is doing at the time
this knowledge can't be verified or
peer-reviewed instead it has to be taken
on faith and because courts can't trust
this all the criminals of Batman has
brought in have had to be released due
to a lack of evidence
suddenly I also hope you notice here is
that Bruce is a much colder person than
he used to be or previously he seemed
detach from his emotions operating with
cold logic but the möbius chair at his
disposal he doesn't really even seem
human whether this is a byproduct of the
fact that he's always been this way and
the chair simply brings it out or
because this is a new aspect of his
personality is really up for us to
debate but the foundation on which Bruce
Wayne operates is that he has the
ability to look beyond the physical
actions of individuals and analyze
people as a whole to this end he's now
under the opinion that humanity's base
instincts are for violence and that for
better or worse Jim Gordon and Gotham
have no choice but to follow his lead
and place those he deems as criminals in
jail and so with the conversation coming
to an end and Bruce Wayne departing we
pick up with him traveling to intercept
several criminals in the midst of
planning robbery now something I'd like
to focus on here for a second is the
nature of the criminal element if I had
to throw my own opinion into the Hat I
think Batman's actually throwing the
baby out with the bathwater the reason
why I say this is because despite their
actions one of the fundamental
principles is separates democracy from
tyranny is the concept of innocent until
proven guilty web MN is done here is
Institute his own philosophy of justice
and again while he had previously done
this before regarding how he gained
information in the end his target was
always apprehended within the confines
of the law itself furthermore rather
than allowing criminals to carry out
their own robbery and then provide the
evidence necessary to stop them instead
he actually transports them to
Antarctica and leaves them there now the
reason why I say this is important is
because for Batman working within the
law it's actually easier now than it's
ever been with a Mobius chair providing
knowledge of all things both past and
present it would be extremely easy for
him to attain the evidence necessary or
even point the police in the direction
of the evidence they need to secure a
case but instead he's taken the most
extreme road stripping individuals of
the right to a fair trial deeming them
guilty due to their plan to commit an
act they haven't actually committed yet
and then holding them accountable for it
and so transitioning to the home of an
unidentified man what the story also
does is give us a chance to ask the
question is what Bruce is doing right
what he arrives at the man's home and
finds him brandishing a knife we learned
that this is actually the man's
ex-wife's apartment in addition to being
drunk his decisions are governed by rage
and that he had been beating his wife
and when she finally became fed up and
decided to leave he made the choice to
plan her murder by hiding in the closet
with a knife and so taking the man and
transporting him to the mascara where
Batman's initially greeted with anger by
the amazons who don't like uninvited
outsiders he presents the man to them
making the case that he beats his women
and that spending some time on the
island will provide him with an
opportunity to better understand how to
adequately treat women
and so the reason behind Bruce Wayne's
harsh methods in dealing with criminals
comes to fruition when we follow him
back to the time of the death of his
parents as they were killed by Joe Chill
now this moment is a stupendous
importance and the reason why is because
it creates a single definitive idea for
Batman despite the fact that he can
capture and arrest criminals prior to
their crimes as much as he wants the one
thing that he can't change is the death
of his parents now the cool thing about
this is that this is a very human moment
for Bruce rather than being the violent
sociopath who strip people of their
rights for the sake of the greater good
in truth if I can be a little dramatic
Bruce Wayne is really just a kid wishing
his parents would come back and so using
his chair to jump back to the
doesn't he looks to take his vengeance
out on Joe Chill the man who had
murdered his mother and father picking
up in Gotham State Penitentiary
Bruce encounters chill for the first
time since he was 18 years old now the
important thing to keep in mind here is
that to be honest Bruce is probably not
acting sane I say this because the
behavior he's demonstrated so far
indicates that despite his methods he's
still a man of reason and conscience but
for this encounter he seems to be
throwing it all out the window and his
anger appears to be coming to a slow
boil working its way up to a fever pitch
initially Batman taunts chill and saying
that he was curious how Joe spent his
days in jail with a pungent toilet and
no window until he dies but when Joe
calls for help
Batman places a shield around the prison
cell that keeps all noise from entering
or leaving following this Batman taunts
Joey Baird asking him what it is that he
feels he deserves regarding creature
comforts and a life of luxury now this
is actually a throwback of sorts to
Batman The Dark Knight issue number zero
by Greg Hurwitz which did a bit of
retelling of Batman's origins in this
story when Bruce Wayne was 18 years old
he had travelled to confront Joe Chill
regarding the murder of his parents
during their confrontation it was
revealed the chill was an alcoholic but
it made the statement that he deserved a
few creature comforts
as a result and while looking for his
next fix he saw Martha Wayne's pearls
robbed them and imp annek shot both
Martha and Thomas Wayne however whether
story does it seems to retcon the Dark
Knight number zero and that Bruce has
Joe confide in him the number of people
that he's killed over the course of his
adult life and when Joe Chill reveals
that it's around 40 people
Bruce transports him to Crime Alley
stating that his only real interest is
in the two individuals who died in this
location Bruce takes his mask off
revealing his identity to Joe Chill
now Bruce revealing his identity to Joe
is simply an instance of intimidation
and then he threatens to spread the word
throughout the prison that Joe's actions
of killing the Wayne's are the reason
for why most of the men are in prison in
the first place as a result if this were
to happen it would be a virtual death
sentence for Joe and that where the
prisoners are not in a position to kill
Batman they are in a position to kill
Joe and so after having his fun and
tormenting him with the possibility of
his own death Bruce uses the power of
the Mobius chair to force Joe to forget
everything that he's seen and heard now
to offer my own opinion I would say that
this would allow Bruce to return to Joe
torment
in this fashion and experience his
reaction of horror each time that it
happened well this may seem a little
extreme to be honest I don't actually
blame Bruce for this and that he has an
opportunity to torment the murderer of
his parents for every single day of his
life and so picking back up in the
Batcave we learned that there's actually
a little more to Bruce's acquisition of
the möbius chair then we were initially
led to believe where he's greeted by
Alfred with a warm dinner
Bruce shows that he's actually suffering
from extreme anguish the reason behind
this is revealed to be due to the fact
that the chair has a mind of its own to
a degree and that has actually been
acting against Bruce now we're not told
exactly what this means I would go as
far as the saying but this is due to the
fact that Jeff Jobs intends to flesh
this out during the main Darkseid war
story but regarding the events as they
unfold here the case that Bruce mace is
that the chair functions as an observer
and a chronicler as opposed to the on
hands approach that Bruce has been
taking as a result not only is it
impacting him physically but it also
seems to make it impossible for him to
leave now as a story comes to an end
where we would expect something on the
order of Bruce attempting to move past
this problem or at the very least put
his mind to tasks in attending to
understand why this is instead he
embraces the change stating that if the
chair allows him to function without any
sustenance or sleep and it's a small
price to pay and that ultimately it
would allow him to focus on and
eventually take down the Joker with that
being said we're going to bring this
video to an end and let me know down in
the comments section if you guys are
interested in seeing any more of the
Darkseid war 1 shots and I will catch
you guys later peace